ce soir voyons la côte normande et la
cuisine au beurre à deauville le bilan
provisoire est assez bon une
fréquentation en hausse en grande partie
grâce aux étrangers l'enquète dans
régaler l'affluence estivale ici est
étroitement liée aux caprices du temps à
deux heures de paris par l'autoroute
un coup de fil suffit à décider si oui
ou non la météo mérite que l'on parte
arpentait les fameuses planches du bord
de mer un chiffre précise le caractère
versatile de la clientèle
la durée moyenne des séjours a été de
deux jours et demi en juillet et de cinq
jours en août 5 jours du fait des
courses hippiques
nous avons fait un mois de juillet très
satisfaisant il a fait un temps superbe
et grâce notamment à la fréquentation
d'une clientèle étrangère qui est venu
en nombre supérieur aux autres années à
peu près de l'ordre de 30 à 35 % de
clientèle est étrangère
nous avons fait un mois d'août toujours
aussi brillant puisque les classiques
traditionnels de l'animation et des
courses à deauville font que nous fixons
une clientèle de haut niveau et des
qualités qui est revenue fidèles cette
année encore à deauville 750 francs la
nuit c'est un minimum dans les hôtels de
grand luxe
ils ont affiché complet cette saison la
clientèle n'a même pas protesté
parait-il après l'augmentation des taxes
de 25% visant cette catégorie
d'établissements chiffre en hausse
également au casino le deuxième de
france +15 % sur les jeux + 10 % sur les
entrées à côté de cette clientèle
fortunée des bourses plus modestes qui
éprouvent beaucoup de difficultés à se
loger et se nourrir au moindre prix
cette partie de la côte normande est
plutôt mal équipé pour le tourisme de
masse à deauville sur 15 cents chambres
d'hôtel on en compte plus de 1000 dans
la catégorie luxe et grand luxe 3 et 4
étoiles
la clientèle s'est comporté pratiquement
comme l'année dernière avec peut-être
peut-être un petit peu plus peut-être un
petit peu plus d'attention quand même
dans les dépenses c'est à dire à savoir
peut-être un petit peu moins de 20 est
peut-être plus de petits menus que ne
leur pas la carte m'enfin c'est pas
quand même c'est pas flagrant si vous
voulez de toute façon il n'y a pas de
chute par rapport à l'année dernière
des restaurateurs globalement satisfait
il est vrai qu'un menu affiché ici à un
prix modeste pleurait souvent comme
suspect pour le commerce des chiffres
également en hausse si l'on constate un
mieux 15% pour l'alimentation
c'est encore mieux 20% pour les
commerces de luxe
seul nuage dans cette saison presque
idyllique l'immobilier de loisirs là on
assiste à une récession dans les ventes
supérieures à 400 mille francs
cela s'explique au dessous de 400 mille
francs il n'y a pas grand chose sur le
marché